hey this is the we're here at the Bandai
Namco booth reporting live and I am
joined by the very lovely Jennifer
Paulson the senior vice president of
marketing for Bandai Namco in Heiser hi
I'm a remote area also I'll come sharpen
and we're going to start off first and
with none other than as you can see
behind there card so this is project
card - it's the next installment of very
frankly clean project cars developed by
Slightly Mad Studios and we are
delivering a hyper hyper realistic
racing experience to you guys so as you
can see here it has VR capabilities so
you really feel like you are in your
favourite supercar but also a wide
variety of classes of cars including
rally cars as well as Indy cars as well
and
project cars - offers full 12 capability
when you war are my three Courtney
moniker ya know you really get an
incredible experience to this and it has
built in eSports capabilities your
friends and a tournament so yeah we're
really looking forward for this game
this league good luck good luck Super
Deluxe Edition that call now they're
saying that this setup would just my
premium by itself can get even further
if you like linking multiple monitors up
because the final form yeah exactly that
you can link three monitors yes okay
which is amazing I mean this to me has
spells the end of humanity as you can
see the gentleman is not going to be
leaving the kiosk anytime soon I think
that's why they have the security I
throw em off and no one can rightfully
separate themselves from this awesome
setup just really crazy right here whoa
all right let's check out more parts of
the booth there's free VIP this year
this is like Europe diner here with so
many hits by the way up next I'm gonna
check out ninokuni so here we are in
another segment of the Bandai Namco
booth and of course this is the ever
lovely ninokuni two revenant Kingdom
developed by level-5 and published by
Bandai Namco it is going to be a ps4 and
PC exclusive but just look at that
lovely artwork and of course when we
come to the revenant Kingdom we had to
pay tribute to the video game of Thrones
queen who is already sitting here on
this lovely throne thank you yeah so you
guys have absolutely knocked it out of
the ballpark you have a little something
for Xbox and then when it came to the
next day for the PlayStation
press release you
drop the bombshell that ninokuni to the
revenant Kingdom was returning it
definitely was a very beloved title
attested with that nice anime artwork
tell us how important this is especially
for the fans in Asia that definitely
gravitate towards the type of RPG style
and its art style yeah so I think a lot
of people really love the first one and
you know we're continuing that in the
revenant Kingdom but also delivering a
brand new story so it's actually a
completely new storyline with new
characters and you'll be following the
King's name as Evans the young king and
he's lost his kingdom and so you go on a
journey with him that reclaim his throne
speaking of the video game of Thrones it
seems like this year you guys are on a
mission to absolutely destroy all the
other kingdoms out there one is 2017
mean with this incredible roster of
video games for Bandai Namco yeah so
we're always looking to deliver you know
a really rich roster that includes all
of the the anime IPS that people love
and also you know our own IPS as well
and I think there'll be a lot more to
come throughout the year and not only
these global titles but also titles
phonetically for Asian consumers and so
that's the kind of balance that we're
looking for
speaking of titles specifically for
Asian consumers as I can say so myself
we're going to check out for me the
blockbuster of the entire you guys like
killed III with this bombshell
Dragonball Fighters that's going to be
our next segment here at the booth let's
check it out
I
absolutely as you can hear my voice a
little hoarse as is yours I'm not sure
what your vision is but hearing she
press release or xbox you guys drop the
full-length trailer you actually
included gameplay in it Dragonball
Fighters I think really sold a thunder I
know there was 42 other titles out there
hey yeah the internet collectively
erupted and what this Dragonball
bringing Dragonball to the masses in
this three-on-three format with that
beautiful 2.5 cell shading mean for you
guys well I think you know we have a lot
of fighting game experience obviously
with second that just came out our
sample and we've teamed up with our
system works for this game so we are on
the holy Union that's not yeah you're
really confident that we were going to
deliver the most awesome fighting game
that Dragon Ball fans have been waiting
for like you I think like me grew up
with Dragonball like from the beginning
all the way through and this is the game
I've been waiting for so I certainly
hope that other fans hoping see that
soon Dragon Ball if it weren't for
Dragonball I don't think my life would
be where it is today that's like through
that I got interested in Japanese and
then I went to go study abroad and I
think for everyone they have a little
story about how Dragon Ball really
transformed their lives
and of course Dragonball does have many
titles across the years but there's
something about this one that is
different from the rest yeah and I it's
odd because you guys have I don't know
the rumors are true but it's you know
only 20 percent completed or
what-have-you but it looks so polished
even at that early stage in the game I
think it I mean it's really when we
first saw it also young man ever gone
online we couldn't wait to share it with
everyone and you know it's like it
really feels like you're fighting in the
anime and that's really translated well
so I think to everyone who gets their
hands on it here are you tried it I did
in fact I was not going to show up to
this thoroughly all you got to do some
video work for the Walker I was like no
I'm not going to do that and then they
said well you know the big boss is is
going to be great thing us with your
presence thank you very much so I had to
come here but a lot of people because
you have not implemented any rules in
the back won't get off the joystick or
the gamepad got to get security now
so I suggest you know just for the
launch of the game you guys people up
your security are there will be a lot of
pickpocketing in the video game scores
but we want to punch again struggling
just to get their hands on this gave me
a mob scene this really is like the
second coming of you know like Jesus
Christ put a lot of people it's like a
religious experience or gives my class
to me and I think I think it takes a lot
of people just as I grew up in Asia with
the comics that were translated in their
local language this is like their time
to really play a title that speak to
them it's not a new IP this is something
I've been with them like since their
birth yeah
well I'm so happy you're excited about
it you can't wait to you know give you
more hands-on time with it early in Asia
and other game shows as well no I don't
think I've seen you around at some of
the major tournaments in Asia using that
this will as you drag the ball players
will find its place alongside it second
in eSports yeah I mean definitely we
hope so I think we're going to expand
our eSports offering and this will be a
cornerstone of that so that definitely
look out for more of that I think the
fighting game community hopefully
they'll embrace lift and it'll grow I
last note I think you need to buy double
this server
you know the server is for the the bail
you guys should announce it sometime
summer but I will collectively crash
your servers and so too will all another
fan you I don't know where to go it'll
look like a DDoS attack but that's
actually the collective internet trying
to access and download the playable when
it's available so definitely look out
for that too something thank you alright
so there you have it that was a nice
little walk through as a Bandai Namco
booth I think we did on the major IPs
and to fund this lavish lifestyle
pre-order yeah really to people up this
is carbon-fibre McLaren behind us I
think that you guys have absolutely
killed it thank you and you should just
do a victory lap around all the other
booths they should not be named but you
guys have really you know not have a
park for you to congratulations Austin
here marketing VP at the night Michael
thanks so much